um good afternoon everyone um my name is
priyana trajan i'm the current director
of the frankie program
in science and the humanities at yale
um it is uh with deep sadness that i
would like to share with you all the
terrible news
of the passing of richard franke
rich was one of the founding duo along
with barbara frankie who has kindly
joined us today
of this flagship interdisciplinary
program the frankie program in science
in the humanities at yale
today we moan the passing of a family
member
a kind generous and wise elder
who guided many of us
to me personally he was an inveterate
cheerleader
keeping track of my research work in
science
in astrophysics sending congratulatory
notes whenever he read about my work
we would meet up over coffee and he
would pepper me with really hard science
questions
you know he really was a space nerd
and had an incredibly curious mind and
was so widely read and knowledgeable
that it was just incredible how he
spanned all these worlds academia the
creative arts the business world
politics and philanthropy
both he and barbara remain strong
supporters of all our activities and
have very fond pre pandemic memories of
all of us the frankie family along with
the young interdisciplinary scholars our
undergrads grads and post-docs getting
together over dinner discussing bold new
ideas
to explore and study he paid attention
to all the talks asked incisive
questions and felt very proud of the
young people whose intellectual
adventures were not limited by academic
silos or disciplinary boundaries
i'm at a loss for words
let me quote from a beautiful poem by
the lebanese american poet khalil gibran
in which this uh the book from pro from
the prophet in which it's a conversation
between the prophet
and a human being
you would know the secret of death but
how shall you find it unless you seek it
in the heart of life
the owl whose nightbound eyes are blind
unto the day cannot unveil the mystery
of light
if you would indeed behold a spirit of
death open your heart wide unto the body
of life
for life and death are one even as the
river and the sea are one
so let's have a moment of silence in his
memory to remember him as he was
deeply empathetic and a beautiful human
being always smiling
energetic and brimming with curiosity to
forever learn
barbara we moan with you and the rest of
your family today
and we wish you strength and courage at
this extremely difficult time
you are both an inspiration to us all
so let's um have a moment of silence
before we start today's program
let's begin
by recognizing our benefactors mr and
mrs richard and barbara frankie
acknowledging the sad loss of mr frankie
last friday
today's talk
is one that we have all been looking
forward to with great excitement
and it is with great pride and pleasure
that i introduce our speaker one of our
own frankie fellows
who started this wonderful project
cross-disciplinary project and despite
many personal challenges health
challenges has emerged victorious
enthusiastic
and super productive in terms of his
work
so the talk today is by diego ellis soto
and the title is collective pulse
uncovering the hidden lives of animals
through music theory and artificial
intelligence
i can tell you all that you're in for a
treat this afternoon
first let me remind you that we are
recording this event and therefore all
participants will
have to have their videos muted for the
duration of the talk
questions may be submitted at any time
in the q and a
feature
so let me introduce
our young and brilliant scholar diego
diego is an uruguayan biologist studying
how biodiversity across the world
responds to future current and future
climatic conditions in a rapidly warming
world work as you all know is extremely
urgent and timely
he tests ecological theory using cutting
edge technologies animal gps collar data
drone imagery citizen science data
satellite imagery statistical modeling
for applied conservation outcomes he's
particularly interested in understanding
how why when and where species move at
local local regional and global scales
this is of course critical in order to
predict the ecological consequences of
increased human activities and changing
climates on biodiversity
while the bulk of his phd work involved
sitting between a computer screen and a
desk chair coding
diego has performed field work and
research on the ecology of giant
tortoises in galapagos islands for the
past nine years and is passionate about
scientific communication as well as his
research were
he joined yale in 2018 and is currently
a fourth year doctoral student in the
department of ecology and evolutionary
biology
besides being a frankie fellow
one that we are extremely proud of diego
is also an early career rafford
conservation explorer a
yale global food fellow
a law ethics and animal program fellow
at the yale law school and an
environmental humanities student grant
awardee
he exemplifies the best of what rich
frankie had in mind for a truly
interdisciplinary scholar working
at the cutting edge using cutting-edge
technologies to answer some really old
profound deep questions
he obtained his undergraduate education
environmental sciences from the
university of trier and his graduate
studies in biological sciences at the
university of consumps
shortly afterward he worked at the max
planck institute for animal behavior
leveraging large amounts of biological
data for hundreds of species across the
world
during this time this is the most
enviable part of his cv he lived in the
galapagos islands for over a year
working with the giant tortoises and
spent several months in the ecuadorian
amazon working with poison frogs he
worked as a dj throughout his time in
germany and performs music at the
interface of natural sounds and
electronic music
i mean i think you know his resume is
just impossibly filled with sort of
these talented things that you know um
he has productively engaged in i don't
know how he has time to do all of this
given how young he is but there you go
he's also very passionate about
scientific communication and of course
his work which as you will see in a
moment just is at the frontier has been
featured in dozens of news outlets
including bbc nature documentaries in
new york times
spanish newspapers abc news yahoo news
and so on so forth
in um addition his most recent work
researches the impacts of altered human
mobility during covet 19 pandemic on
wildlife across the world and has been
endorsed by the united nations so kovid
as you all know the global pandemic not
only impacted us humans but the entire
natural world it was traumatic for the
entire natural world
diego aspires to bring the humanities
and the natural sciences together both
at work and in his spare time he
performs in electronic music festivals
across the globe and he's increasingly
interested in combining electronic music
with soundscape ecology using open
source technology
we are also delighted today to have
matthew sitter professor in the practice
of sound design at yale school of drama
who will be joining diego today in his
presentation
professor sutter has been a leading part
of this project alongside diego since
the beginning we're particularly
grateful for his continued support
through personally difficult times for
diego new zealand bond composer matthew
sutter has taught at yale university
since 1999 first in the department of
music and since 2002 at the david geffen
school of drama he is also affiliate
faculty at the center for collaborative
arts and media at yale often combining
music technology with acoustic forces
matthew has composed operas dance works
and music for all kinds of theatrical
productions chamber music and sacred
sound installations course for
television and so on his work in opera
and dance includes don juan in prague in
collaboration with the director david
chambers for the bard summerscape
festival
and the um
which was revised for the mozart prague
festival the guggenheim works and
process series and
and the bam next wave festival
he composed zoom slides television
series real pacific and anna mar
brooke's documentary feature film loy
mata
he has been involved with yale rep
theater productions that include the
intelligence uh design of jenny chow
all's well that ends well the winter's
tale arcadia and an enemy of the people
he's extremely distinguished a fulbright
scholar and he received a doctorate in
doctorate and composition from columbia
university i could spend the entire hour
telling you about the wonderful
accomplishments of the two scholars
today but without further ado let me
turn it over to diego diego and matthew
thank you so much for speaking to us
today and sharing your ideas
thank you so much priya for his kind
introduction um thank you miss frankie
um
for letting us dream big with the
support so um none of this would have
been possible without this initial
support from the frankie project and i
hope to show how um an initial support
towards students can snowball into a
larger project that
is collective pulse now so thank you for
believing in us
um
today i'm very excited to present that
joint work um i'm extremely flattered to
be giving this talk it's a professional
highlight for me thank you for the
opportunity
um this is a large team effort in a
truly collaborative manner as hopefully
you will see in the last acknowledgement
of my slide involving people on farms
local hospitals engineers music
musicians
composers ecologists conservationists um
it's it's been truly a pleasure and a
privilege to be able to work with every
single one of these people and
particularly matthew for the patience
the mentorship and the expertise and
just
the creativity to to dream big and take
this forward um today we will be talking
about new ways of exploring the natural
world and looking at the hidden lights
of animals through a bird's eye view
literally
using new emerging technologies that let
us capture
the voyages of animals and how they
sound like and how they look like and
the danger of what happens if we lose
this incredible beauty in the natural
world by human activities
and
i would like to introduce the main
characters of today's band
we have flying pigeons on a piano we
have homing pigeons on a different piano
we have stickleback fish on the drums
and we have eight termites that decided
to make a mixture of electronic music
and classic guitar
um
so the um
the beauty of the natural world knows no
limit many of us probably have seen
these incredibly flocks of tenths of
thousands of birds flying at once in
unison
and this looks incredibly harmonic and
people have wondered for a long time how
do these rules go together are they do
they have telepathy houses tens of
thousands of animals organized at unison
and to many people like matthew this
probably looks like music and he will
expand a little bit more on this
at the same time how i started
this is me on the left next to my
brother i'm the one with the glasses as
a five-year-old i guess i've always
liked uh animals in biology and on the
right side
i sort of always like music i'm the
little one watching my brother jealously
playing the flute while my dad is
looking at musical sheets but i always
played my cards right this was outside
an airport where we asked adults for
money to then buy candy and some
dinosaur toys so i think i've always had
a passion for music getting a lot of
different people together to get the
most out of a project as a collective
and inspiration of the natural world
i actually started in the humanities i
started as a journalist and then quit i
went to germany to study biology little
did i know that would change my life
fast forward 25 years
i now study animal migrations
particularly across the world and how
they
move and how biodiversity is moving
under global warming here we can see a
picture of the globe where every single
pink line is an individual animal
trapped with a little gps collar that
allows us to monitor the voyages of
these animals and we can see almost that
animals are almost like veins or pulses
across the world as they are following
snow
snowmelt in the northern hemisphere
they're going up and as snow comes back
animals are going down into the southern
hemispheres almost like a collective
pole through the planet and this is
something that i've been investigating
in my phd for a very long time
and um
in my laboratory at the ideal university
led by walter yetz we're also very
interested in creating tools that allow
the public to
visualize these
voyages of animals and represent the
hidden lives of animals bringing them
closer to the public such as animal
lives
but also during the last years i've been
focusing more on music production using
a variety of different softwares
on my phd i use a lot of different
technological advances to improve the
way that we can monitor and document
biodiversity and how it's changing for
example on the right side we have over
900 satellites measuring environmental
conditions 24 hours a day that allow us
to measure the pulse of the planet in
terms of vegetation greenness as seen on
the left
and this is incredibly important and
increasingly important because we're
currently in the sixth mass extinction
and this is a human man-made catastrophe
with human activities driving several
species to extinction and what's even
worse is there's many species we don't
even know about and we are losing not
just important ecosystem services but
also the incredible beauty and of nature
their sounds the way they look like and
it's really important to document this
and better understand the change through
time
um this is for example an article that
highlights some scientific communication
of my research lab where through maps
we're able to visualize biodiversity
closer to humans and actually because of
this frankie project i've started to
think maps are really really incredible
way of communicating narratives and
scientific stories to humans but music
can be the same too
and
this is something that we are
increasingly able to do we can document
human activities through time and we're
able to understand the impacts of
biology on these changes for example we
can see how urbanization and human
activities are changing ecosystems but
also what ecosystems sound like
and by here i want to say that this is
by no way and something that we have
invented here there has been many people
that have pioneered this work and i want
to highlight two of them namely benjamin
patterson who
was an incredible artist and
was imposed composed
was employed as a classic bassist but
uh he was denied employment because of
his race
and um
he recently died in 2016 but to my
knowledge he was the first person
exploring how to make music with ants
and what
mr patterson did he put a music sheet on
the ground and tossed ants on it and
followed their movements by drawing on a
pen
and here you can see mr patterson trying
to make musical sheet out of a data of
ants and he laters mentioned that while
this is not music or musical it's a new
method of making music
i also want to acknowledge work by
bernie kraus a soundscape ecologist and
he created the soundtrack of apocalypse
now and on the left we can see mr kraus
deploying some sensors to look at some
microphones to look at habitat changing
ecosystems and on the right we can see
mr krauss with one of the first mooc
synthesizers such as matthew has in the
back
to make music
and mr krause also said
a picture is worth a thousand words but
a soundscape is worth a thousand
pictures
and this is actually incredibly
important
and mr krause has recently wrote an
incredible book called the great animal
opera with interesting insights as of
how humans learned how to dance based on
the natural world and his concept of the
animal opera was covered by the sydney
bnl and what you can see there are sound
waves of the natural world on the
orchestra house in the background so
there's increasingly appreciation also
in the larger public around the work of
documenting soundscapes and documenting
biodiversity
and this is incredibly important also as
a biologist wearing my global change
biology hat because
um mr kraus recording from the 60s
allows to document not just how sounds
and ecosystems has changed but whether
species are still there or not and why
this might be and how fragile
soundscapes might be due to human
activities so it's an incredibly
powerful tool of scientific
communication but also to understand the
natural world from a scientific
perspective
and
what is new here in our project is that
we are um
trying to document and leverage these
incredible technologies that are
available to us as scientists namely
animal tracking technologies that let us
put up satellite attack on an animal and
follow it its entire lifetime computer
vision that allows us to track hundreds
of animals simultaneously as we can see
here in the middle termites of fish
up to the right side where we have
smartphone apps that have uh machine
learning algorithms that allow us to
identify any bird calling in real time
you're going to see a cap
chicory i think um arrive and being
recognized almost instantly by these
algorithms
so we're able to leverage this
incredible amount of biodiversity data
for conservation purposes ecology but
also to bring
these incredibly fragility of the
natural world and incredible beauty uh
closer to the public
and um we are not alone here as i said
there's many people have thought deeply
about this and aristotle mentioned even
in his book the anima written 2 000
years ago that every kind of animal
should be studied and revealed as it has
something incredibly beautiful in the
natural world
um well think fast forward 2 000 years
now we have really good powerful ai that
allows us to track um
a lot of different objects humans and
species and incredible detail and we're
able to leverage this for tech for
conservation and for good
um as shown here in 2015 by rosenthal
and l this is a facebook social network
of fish here we can see a number of fish
and um the graphs and the notes between
them is the relationship that each of
these fish has to their neighbor and
their local interactions so we cannot
just uncover the hidden lives of single
animals but what's even more fascinating
is their collective behavior
and
incredible research and collective
behavior has shown that actually very
simple rules in nature
determine very complex patterns uh as
seen here there's three different
collective states that animals could be
in and these are largely determined by
animals don't want to be too far away in
groups they want don't want to be too
close together and they want to move at
a similar speed and we could think of
these three different states as being
almost universal in nature swarming can
occur in mosquitoes it can occur in in
fish
polarization when there's almost a
harmonic very directional movement is
almost like a v formation in fish or a v
formation in flying fish and milling can
occur in fish or if any of you ever
wants to google a reindeer cyclone it's
when reindeers move in a circle very
familiar to watch
but what on earth has this to do with
music theory and music
well this is when i had the pleasure of
meeting matthew right before the covert
19 pandemic and we started talking about
these things and it has been an absolute
pleasure and privilege to work with him
and i would like to give matthew the
work the word to explain a little bit
more
thank you diego and
good afternoon everybody
so
as diego was uh just
explaining
uh the the basic rules of of collective
animal behavior and this is uh
a composer explaining to scientists
which i acknowledge is that uh animals
want to move in a common average
direction common average speed and
common average distance from each other
those are the rules of harmony
that's why that's how i teach
students how to compose
a chorale in the style of bach they are
the rules that palestrina used and
they're still the same rules that we use
to write pop songs so if i uh
talk a little bit about the
uh the ideas behind it so when i when i
look at say
uh the murmuration of starlings you saw
that uh one of the video that diego
showed earlier on i look at that and i
think that looks
like music
and but it's not it's not a trivial
thing to work out how to take that
three-dimensional behavior even if you
have really elaborate exact tracking
data and then map that onto musical
parameters so by musical parameters i
mean pitch
rhythm duration articulation phrasing
timbre which is tone color etc so the
first place or the obvious place that
that we
wanted to explore is that we if we have
for example
uh xy coordinates uh on a cartesian um
plane uh tracking individual animals but
then we could map that to say pitch
and we in music theory we talk about
pitch space
and in this case we're looking at what's
called the toenets which is 19th century
uh music theory it's not this is not not
new and you can see that
moving left to right
we've got
uh on the on the horizontal we have
perfect fifths and then on the diagonal
we have um various kinds of thirds major
and minor thirds and if you look at the
triangulation in the middle c e flat g
that's a c minor triad and then if you
flip
underneath c g e that's a c major triad
so there's a way in which you can
theoretically navigate around a pitch
space and that coordinates
to it um we've even started to look at
more complex uh shapes here we've got
a uh a
toenails in the shape of a
taurus uh which our mathematical friends
and sisters actually still
two-dimensional i wanted to call it
three-dimensional and was um quickly
disappears uh of that so um
so as i mentioned this is not a uh
a trivial thing to work out well how do
you make music from from this data so
we've had some breakthroughs recently
that i'd like to to share just to give
you a taste of
of uh where we are we are uh hitting
so uh here
i have
the beginnings of
uh taking the the data that we have for
a group of ten
homing pigeons
and uh so the the
the uh the data is around 150 000
uh lines which includes xy coordinates
and also other information to work out
whether they are milling swarming or
they're polarized
and so simply what i've done is we've
we've taken their
uh those the
cartesian coordinates and the
breakthrough which was which actually
came well how do we visualize this and
through thinking through visualizing it
for you
we met the cartesian coordinates to
polar coordinates and then lo and behold
we found a way of mapping that to to
pitch space so what i'm going to play
here which is actually run is going to
run in real time it's not a recording
it's taking the data
of x y coordinates turning into pull up
coordinates and then mapping that to a
pitch space and then sending that to
another program which is going to play
back uh choral samples so now in theory
we have a uh a choir of of ten pigeons
uh and it to me it sounds like music but
that might be debatable but it's it's a
it's a first uh step here we go
uh
[Music]
so that's the beginning of
something that at least from a from a
compositional point of view i really do
feel that we've got something
uh to work with so just to show you
briefly
what it looks like in terms of
actual
music so what we were playing then
was uh recorded in in real time
and and there we have
pigeons
homing pigeons producing
chords that if i were to look at this uh
i would say this is
music
and so i'm pretty excited about the
potential for this
uh
[Applause]
the next step of course would be to
take this and then and then map the um
the movement onto a surround sound
system so a kind of cinematic experience
uh it might even extend as as far as say
a virtual reality experience where you
could be a pigeon in the and the flock
of pigeons
uh while listening to
uh the the realization
of of this so this we're really excited
for this and and something that that
it was an unexpected thing for for me is
to look at say these recordings of
environments
that diego is going to be getting into
and
and making musical realizations of those
so it's not just the flocking or the
schooling data but actually taking uh
environmental recordings and then
mapping that onto musical spaces so the
the sonification and visualization of
day of data uh which is something that
i'm really interested in
is a way of
of showing people what is happening in
the environment
so it's one thing to sort of say
here's you know here's that here's
what's going on in terms of some kind of
abstract description it's another thing
to express it through
art so that's part of the project and
i'm really excited to be working with
diego and i will hand it back to him
thank you
i think thank you matthew um
um
um we are not the first people to talk
about data certifications um nasa has
been working on this for quite some time
and here we can see what galaxy sounds
like
different colors are different pitches
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
but i do believe that
one of the major advantages
and progresses of this project
is um that we are applying both musical
theory and biological theory for example
as the toenails that matthew has
mentioned
we are also adding we've performed
apologies
we're also exploring different ways of
playing with chord progressions and
feelings for example as some of these
collective states in which animals can
be such a swarming or whether they are
transitioning from one state to another
these are somewhat more chaotic or
weakened for example at different chord
progressions to them to evoke emotions
as animals change from a more
chaotic system such as swarming to a
polarized state
and in addition we are exploring new
ways of such as the
we call it the pigeon reader what
matthew just showed you almost of
creating new synthetic
synthesizer or instruments that artists
could use
and the interesting part of this is that
this would represent represent a direct
connection of nature with an artist so
it actually really physically matters
where the artist is in space and how the
output of some of this music might sound
like
and um
i'm going to jump a little bit into some
variables of interest that we've been
interested as biologists and i will
showcase you four different examples of
music that was generated by different
animals and how this has a little bit
evolved in complexity through time as
we've learned so much from this project
and if we have a group of fish for
example we could look at a single fish
we could look at how fast are you going
how fast is this fish accelerating
what's the distance between its next
fish we could also look at the
collective and say
what's the average speed of the
collective where is the collective
um average position
what's the degree of
alignment among these fish called
polarization how much are they moving
around their own axis rotation
is this a collective state that is
stable such as polarized or are they
trying to transition
and i'm going to try to showcase some of
these parameters we've been playing
around with with some pigeons
in this example we split our pigeon
group into three and these three groups
of pigeons
represented three different notes on a
keyboard and it's going to sound very
clunky
[Music]
digo we are losing the sound somehow
could you turn it up
is this better
yes
so this is a very chaotic clunky sound
as displayed in the art on the bottom
left and i'm excited to say that we
currently have an art exhibit opening
that's going to display all this art and
we will show you a little bit later a
glimpse of it
our next artists on the ensemble today
are stickleback fish and um
this is an image of these fish in a fish
tank and i showed this to an artist at
sai city and he was surprised by how
beautiful this was and i said it was
made by the animals themselves this is
their reality this is was their
experience in a couple hours on a fish
tank so
we are communicating with different
artists and sculptures of exploring new
ways of representing the unnatural world
through the animal lives themselves
and this is we have applied the same
principle we have a group of i think it
was 10 fish in a fish tank we have split
this into groups of three so if you're
close to two others you will become one
key on a pitch space
as matthew was explaining and as the
fish moves the different keys will
change
[Music]
and it's very interesting because you
can even
listen that these animals are in a
different medium fish can turn around
because they're in water a pigeon can't
just make a
full stop and then turn around so we can
even listen the different mediums in
which these animals live and experience
the world and these are the actual
homing pigeon that matthew was showing
you these were a track with gps callers
and um every single one and they're part
actually of a seminal paper that
discovered leadership in pigeons who's
leading a flock of pigeons so we're
actually using cutting edge scientific
data for this data
certification this is um a previous
version of matthew's pigeon reader and
on the top right we can see the art this
is the actual tracks and the actual data
so the raw excel sheet plotted on a
landscape it looks like a artist just
made a splash and every single caller is
a different individual and here we're
going to see matthew performing and
practicing live at our opening at sci
city earlier this week
[Music]
it was so much fun um
and here we have my personal favorites
these are eight termites on a petri dish
and here i want to highlight and
showcase how our
artificial intelligence computer
algorithm works namely it's able to
track every single termite
and each different termite is tracked in
its position and its time and its unique
identity
and what we get out of this
is the raw data of
a time a frame a position in x space a
position in y space and identity and
this is the raw building block for a lot
of these musical parameters and
collective behavior parameters that
we're creating this means that we can
make this for almost any single animal
now on and we have the code and we are
planning to make the code fully
available in public in github we want
everyone to be able to use this and
claim by no way that we should be the
only ones doing this
and
in this
piece made by eight different termites
we have um
an individual termite on uh
i think it was on a guitar yes and then
we have three different parameters
collective behavior parameters of
termites translated into music in three
different pianos so the only thing i did
as human being was assign different
instruments to different parameters of
these ants
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and
besides just computer vision artificial
intelligence i also mentioned these
credible advantage in sound recognition
and for this we've put little bird spy
microphones and computers raspberry pies
and audio moth
with
nine dollar microphones from amazon the
cheapest i could find and we put them on
the yale farm for a month and we're
planning on keeping them up a little bit
longer to document bird migration and
what was incredible is that we detected
60 species at the farm in this four week
experiment and documented over 2 000 20
000 observations
and if you're wondering who was the
loudest and most most common bird you
guessed right it was the blue jay very
loud bird very beautiful bird and what
this ai also allows us to do
is it allows us to document the species
but also a confidence of how certain the
ai is that it has documented a certain
species so beyond musical interest this
is incredibly exciting for bird
biodiversity because we can document
um biodiversity through time 24 hours a
day for under 200 dollars so this could
be and is currently a game changer in
biodiversity research especially
thinking and communicating about this
work with artists musicians
activists and
it has changed the way that i see a
little bit my own science because um
if
we can use all these tools to educate
the next generation of scientists policy
makers and musicians children we could
empower them to collect and sample and
listen to their neighborhoods learn
computer programming on the way which is
a really important skill
learn about the natural world become
stewards of their environment have a lot
of fun doing it spend time outside which
has been really important during covet
and make music and art out of it so this
is called steam so it's stem humanities
and arts
and
i'm thrilled that sai city gave us the
opportunity to open an art display this
week in this incredible building and
it's open until friday morning so please
check it out if you have the time the
building actually looks like a fish tank
and a bird nest and
we opened this award and this was
as a basic scientist this was my
imagination of what this art exhibit
could have looked like i had never done
this and i think we actually came quite
close so i invite you to take a
collective plunge with me here this is
the building and here we have
someone exploring the birds by
microphone trying to play a bird sound
and see if it can be documented to the
right side we have a little poster
describing what we found at the farm who
the loudest singer was who ate the farm
compost scientific communication in the
back we have the music generated by our
eight termite artists
um in addition as i mentioned the next
generation is all that is what matters
the most because um they will follow up
with this work and i'm very proud to say
that we launched a launch an art exhibit
contest
throughout new haven um asking children
of any age to paint any wildlife in
connecticut and we made flyers both in
english and spanish and we were
overwhelmed by the talent the incredible
imagination of the artists and here are
the winners we have lilian delgado who
documented every single owl in
connecticut we have leslie powerlack a
second grader documenting birds and
mammals and we have alina zan making a
3d chicken and she sent me several
pictures of the process which is just
mind-blowing
and here we have all the other artists
um
and i have to say that because we made
this advertisement in spanish we got 40
percent of uh
emails and submissions that were in
spanish and the robin was the most
common animal drawn and as a
biodiversity scientist it's interesting
that birds and mammals were the most
frequent ones
being painted by children
and
i'm trying to
think about a more 10 000 foot view
about this whole concept i i love the
idea of generating new ways of
visualizing the natural world and
solidifying
and bringing it back into the hands of
the human artists and this is for
example how our little microphones
in real time can be put into the hands
of artists such as matthew and i have to
say that last week was the first time
ever that we practiced music because of
the covet 19 pandemic most of this work
has been done on zoom and it was an
absolute pleasure to just
brainstorm and encode and make music
together we're incredibly lucky to have
been supported by um artists and cancer
survivors of yale's milo hospital and
these are origami cranes made by
patients in the hospital and
there's a japanese tradition that if
there's a thousand origami cranes all
your dreams will become true and you
will have good health
and i'm very grateful that these
incredible art pieces were lent to us
you can see them at the smilow hospital
and i love the fact that they're in
bright colors
and we also got
incredibly smile of rocks that um
just these are the moments that remind
me that before a scientist i'm also a
human being and
just reading these just springs my
curiosity into a million pieces and i'm
going to read some of them because
they're so powerful
dance to your own music
the birds sing even when it rains
the song of the earth writes the music
of my soul
listen closely
even the trees exhale their own love
songs
sing the song you were born to sing
be still and listen the earth is singing
and
these moments are
besides my being a scientist these
moments just bring me back and
make me think so much bigger than my
scientific research and what the impact
could be of this project also to bring
joy to people and
promote education and equity in a just
way
and we also were very lucky to have
three art pieces by local
artists and scientists that are on
display on the art gallery
and these are just some of the images
incredible building if you have the
chance please go
and this is matthew me performing live
for the first time ever with the pigeon
gregorian choir
and here's a colleague as a collective
pulse trying to change the stream of
music and that's totally fine
um
and
this is another fact of
so many things that i've learned by
working with humanities artists and i
invited some of my friends who are
dancers to participate and i said if you
come you can dance
so they did and so i did and this just
sprung my creativity to uh gave me new
ideas and make me a better scientist
what if we map all these things into
dancers
and the last piece of music i will play
today is a sneak peek into an electronic
music production made by the termites
where again the only parameters that i
decided as a human were the instruments
they play
and here we have four different colors
of ants which just means that i've
looked into four different patterns
of the entire group at once and mapped
them into different music space
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
and
to bring this back together what i've
learned through this art exhibit
by collaborating with scientists artists
musicians having an incredible team
behind us everything i've shown today is
a collective effort um
and the most important people are the
ones that i will show in my last slide
but every single city
can probably do some of what we've shown
today every city has a school
and we could uh teach steam there
every city has a little farm or a green
space or a vacant lot or an urban garden
where we could document biodiversity
through food justice and make music out
of a farm i'm excited to make yale farm
music with chicken being hi-hat shovels
being snares and birds being the melody
a lot of places have hospitals or
community centers or universities so i
see
this whole presentation of collective
pools that we've demonstrated today as a
very larger envelope and umbrella of
bringing the natural world technology
art and humanity closer together just
like um the general purpose of the
frankie program as envisioned by mr mrs
frankie
and you might be asking what's next
um
i've learned a lot about working with
the humanities in this project spring my
creativity
my curiosity
i love the fact that a lot of the times
artists sit back and let people be and
explore which is a little bit different
than how we work in the sciences i
learned about communication being very
clear
interdisciplinary work non-verbal
communication data visualization emotion
the subjectivity of interpretation
the hard questions our artists ask and
that small grants
make us dream big
um i've also learned from my dancing
friends that this is something i want to
do later maybe each one of these dancers
is a collective and what if we try to
reconstruct through their movement the
music that they were singing to is that
possible there's gonna be so much
variation and each time they dance will
be so unique maybe we can recreate this
i have no idea but i'm excited to find
out
i'm excited to
explore more the sounds of entire
ecosystems and how they have changed
through time how do the ecosystems from
1960 sounded of mr krauss versus how
they sound now in 2022 and artificial
intelligence allows us to split sounds
into the natural sounds and human sounds
for example with great ease so i'm very
excited about this we could make music
about every national park in the united
states
what does the underwater sound
also something we'll be tackling
exploring more musical chord progression
with
matthew's mentorship
working more with the local community in
new haven which is
the biggest
excitement of this entire work was
opening my email and seeing artwork from
kids to be honest that has been the
highlight of this project to me
personally
and stay tuned because more is coming
we're just getting started we have
another opening on saturday we have a
climate bauhaus at the center for
collaborative arts and media please come
this is actually art made by uh
dana carlos but this is made out of
termite data it's going to be a large
print so please check it out
and this is the large team that i was
talking about that has made everything
happen and please take a second to look
at the interdisciplinary nature of these
people
we've gone
anything from people in a hospital local
community workers engineers
ecologists musicians
artists it's an absolute privilege to
work with all of these and with this i
just want to say thank you all for
listening
thank you so much
diego for that absolutely fantastic
mind-blowing talk and thank you matthew
for
um helping uh with the formulation and
the sonification of these natural sounds
um we are um i'm just so proud that the
frankie program um helped you get a
start uh on this absolutely wonderful
really ambitious project and we wish you
the best
and so here's uh you know let's all clap
and give you a round of applause we so
wish we could have done this in person
as well
but um ty did you want to take over and
handle the questions i think we have a
couple coming
absolutely so just a reminder to the
audience to please submit your questions
not in the chat feature but in the q a
and we have one already uh
so diego uh thank you for a fascinating
presentation i'm compelled by your
statement that music can be as powerful
a narrative tool as maps for telling the
story of ecological change over space
and time
could you speak more to the storytelling
potential of sonifying
rather than only
visualizing ecological data
sure i'm going to answer quickly and
probably matthew has a lot of wisdom to
share in there too
matthew
the interesting part between
say a video of an animation of a map or
as we have seen imagine the
spring slowing the curve of covet and 2d
is that
with data certification we can generate
emotions we can say or we can almost
anticipate what's next if we find
certain patterns in our ears we can say
okay we're going up that must mean maybe
that the bird is going up a thermal
and or i have a heads up that is going
to go down
and so the interpretation of music
allows us to disentangle
my subjective view much more complex
patterns in a very interesting way
and
yeah so the interesting thing about
sound in general
is that you can hear something once
and then not hear it again for quite a
number of years decades even hear it
again and you're back in the same place
and time that you were before so we have
a remarkable
memory for um
tone color
so there's that where our visual
memories are unreliable
and i once had a fascinating
conversation with the detective in new
york he said if someone describes a a
crime entirely in visual terms there's
something wrong with your story if they
do not mention
smell or sound
something is something serious is
missing so there's an interesting thing
the other thing about sound that that is
is remarkable is that you can layer
sound you can have multiple layers
together and it will make sense i mean
that that's literally the the meaning of
of harmony uh so that i think in terms
of
sonification and sort of representing
multiple layers of data um then there's
there's there's a tremendous
potential there
so the way that our brains work for
example is if you hear if you have
multiple um people speaking at the same
time we have difficulty passing language
but if you have multiple
instrumentalists playing at the same
time we do we we love that uh so there's
you know there's tremendous uh potential
uh and i think bringing the two together
for how does the visualization and
sonification work
uh
um together and then there are another
thing that i i didn't mention when when
i work with
the raw data you know whether it's
playing around with the termites or and
i've i've worked with uh myself
at the at the
um
the school of medicine he is a
neuroscientist and as a comparative
medicine
looking at um this is a little
distressing crying baby mice and then
mapping that um that onto musical
parameters there's something
authentic about the data because it's
producing sounds and shapes that i would
not have done on my own as a composer so
i'm i'm hearing things new and i think
people
possibly recognize it even that that
sort of initial experimentation with the
pigeons there's something really
something's going on there uh and and i
think it uh
i think that's what we're trying to get
at it's like can you and can you
actually tell the difference between
these these species whether
in terms of what we're doing it's just
we're making decisions in terms of what
we're the sounds we're using but we're
not choosing the notes or the rhythms uh
and so i think there is there's
a really interesting
experiment to be to be done there but i
think the the most important thing is
um
uh is our
memory of placing sounds and time in
place and if you're looking at
the loss of
of um sound worlds and this is the work
of of of bernie krauss and he's been
doing these recordings for years and
years and years and you when you layer
them up over decades it's
remarkable and of course it's
just deeply distressing um so i think
this is one way to kind of get at that
and making it clear to
to the to the public so that's a
wonderful question
um thank you megan
thank you uh okay from our next
participant another commendation
wonderful work a question about tracking
insects especially regarding the ants
and termite work how would you track
insects in their natural environment as
opposed to petri dishes i was wondering
the same thing and
the participants as thinking especially
about bees
different sounds different
relation
yeah they're um about the tracking
through computer vision there i have to
give a shout out to my alma mater and
past employer the max planck institute
for animal behavior and the newly formed
center for the study of advanced
collective um work from ian cousin and
his group has been pioneering computer
vision and tracking of freely animals
um i would recommend reading papers um
there's a computer vision package called
tractor
um
there's a computer vision package called
t-rex
from tristan
walter and ian cousin elif 2018 i think
and then there's also a paper in a
python package called deep post kit
from blair costello young cousin and a
few other people so i would start by
getting a very clear background i'm not
an insects person at all i work with
ginormous tortoises that move very slow
and live forever that's why
i have it easy in my research um but
those were places i would explore with
um center for the advanced study of
animal collective they probably have a
couple answers they're working with
um
ants building bridges and how the
collective helps shape these structures
that i bionic in time they work with
social networks of bees i would that
would be a good starting point
thank you
next question do animals change their
behavior from the sound they generate
using your code it would be cool to know
whether they make they move to make
sounds they like or enjoy so
uh working on a feedback uh there and
again cheers for an amazing presentation
and that's a really good question i'm
not 100 sure i understand it but um so
there's a lot of research
looking at playback experiments to see
for example how would a
zebra react if it hears a lion
and so that sort of research has been
done extensively also to look at how
plastic animal responses are
um
whether or not animals like certain
music i am not sure i'm sure there's a
lot of
psychological research into whether dogs
like classical music or not
i would have to see that's a really good
question i might try it out with my
neighbor's dog
okay
but music software was used to map the
termite music
logic mainstream garage band
and we use ableton and um in its
simplest form the video that you see
there was garageband where we literally
just dragged
almost randomly instruments to see if it
sounded it sounded beautiful but uh most
of the more complex patterns that
matthew is using is from a software
ableton
okay and a follow-up question from the
same participant and for the termites
was pitch mostly determined by position
of the termites if so how were other
parts of the music like volume
determined
matthew and you want to interject him
uh sorry sorry where is this which
question is this
sorry uh aaron's question here uh was
pitch mostly determined by position of
the termites
and if so how were other parts of the
music like volume determined
uh yeah so i think in the case of the
termites it was mostly um coordinate um
position
and uh
some some some of the the way in which
the the music software interacts with
that is also producing nuance
um which is
you know
accents and um
dynamic variation so that's not in that
case it's not really coming directly
from
uh the um
[Music]
uh
from from the termites
i mean it could because we have enough
data to map that onto them in
in one of the videos though the
the one where you see the petri dish and
um the musical instruments there shout
out to john koth uh kos who's electric
engineer helping with this project we
actually were able to map chord
progressions based on the collective
state of the system so
if at a given time point say our excel
sheet says these eight termites are in
polarized state it would play different
chords done if 20 rows later all the
termites are like far away from each
other that would be a transition state
so we're actually able to as matthew
said the pitch is determined by the
position but also the some of the chords
are determined by the collective state
of the system which is really
interesting because we're playing with
the group and the individual so you
could almost think in future work
someone making the background noise and
a single pigeon or an individual playing
the melody
yeah i mean there's a little bit of of
um
some kind of accidental discovery so
from when the animals move from position
to position the velocity of that
movement can produce really interesting
musical results which
were surprising to us although it's not
that's not programmed indirectly that's
coming from the interaction between the
data and and the musical software so
it's a there's a gift um you know happy
accidents uh but we could the next step
for example
uh
is to look at say velocity and position
to not only control pitch
uh but to to control um
uh spectral information so in when in
any musical sound there's there's going
to be uh you know harmonic content and
that that harmonic content will change
over time that produces
um
a nuance and shape and and
and a single musical note for example so
that's that i think there is something
potential there's a lot of potential
there when you're looking at say the
memoration of of stylings where you get
these sort of darker shapes and and
shading and things like that i mean
there's so many animals it might it
wouldn't make sense seems to map them
all onto a single pitch
but you could control like the filtering
of it um so we we're also getting it
into psychoacoustics here um so there's
a there's a kind of psychological
testing element to this which is is
potentially really
um
exciting too so going back to the
original question like what what does
sonification
offer and it and it's also it does have
this sort of psychological dimension too
which is
um is you know i think it has a lot of
potential
okay we have many questions as it's a
measure of how engaged the audience is
your wonderful presentation
beth asks what if any impact do the
sounds made by the animals have when
sonifying their movement do you ever
integrate their natural sounds with the
instrumental sounds and if so is it
harmonic
we have started to experiment
with that and uh
so we we have uh these ones i had the an
audio mark in my backyard uh just
sitting there for a month and and yes
it records you know records every 20
minutes so we have like absolutely
enormous amounts of
of
these recordings and i mean it really
does work just to play the recording up
using say the merlin app from the the
cornell ornithology lab and it will
identify it um so the idea is to
create ambient
backgrounds that are that are
essentially filtered um you know
filtering out i-95 which is also not too
far away from my house
and uh and you can create rather
wonderful shifting
um
uh musical textures uh and the idea is
that we know we would put those behind
the the
the more frenetic um
uh tracking data so that's i'm i'm
really glad that that someone had that
observation that's a
yeah good good thought
yeah that's as much you said that's a
great great point and um yeah i'm
i'm working on a song called glitch crap
where i want to map some melodies made
by craps using computer vision but also
the sound they make when they close
their
uh whatever this is called so stay tuned
it will come to my song
yeah please share it with us we'll post
it
okay an evocative question from stephen
some giant tortoises still alive today
were also alive when beethoven went deaf
how do we tell the story of a 200 year
old life through music can we bring the
living tortoise and dead beethoven
together
i think matthew might answer this
question as he has been working on an
opera with
people who were uh oh yes
so i'm working on an opera about alan
turing and uh we've trained it that the
libretto is written by an ai we're using
gpt2 and gpt3 and we've trained it only
on uh turing's published papers and also
books that we knew that he had read as a
child and then and then you ask the ai
can computers think cam machines
thinking you get these
these rather extraordinary
answers so i think
there's possibly potential to use
artificial intelligence for
predictive
sound making it and it's we have done
some experiments with that you can use
this these same algorithms can be used
for for images as well so it's not gbt2
and gpt3 are a natural language uh model
so primarily they're there to for for
for language construction but you can
use them for sound and and um
image is as well so so uh yeah so
that's kind of a holy grail but you're
sure
something to aspire to
uh from richard what about tracking
radiant shifts in internal parameters
such as temperature electrical activity
etc
that's a great idea and
one of my phd chapters is actually
to see whether animals can predict
weather and i think anyone who has seen
a bird flying knows where thermals are
so
that's a really good idea we have
increasingly a good ability to track the
physiology of animals in the wild and we
have uh mechanistic models that are
based on energy expenditure of animals
that allow us to
we could build on these theories and
create these principles just how we have
created the principles of collective
behavior and translate those to um
to physiology i'm kind of improvising
here but if a mice eat something you
could look at its um heart rate or you
could look at its caloric intake and
play around with that and maybe the
sound of cake eaten by mice sounds
different than a carrot i don't know
there was richard prom suggestion
actually when he came to visit when he
when we he visited the exhibition and
the performance at sci city um and he
thought that that would be
a way of of of of tracking um
so certainly those stylings and things
and you know these sort of mass
demonstrations that you see in nature so
that's so that's a great suggestion
great uh one more question before we
wrap up
um
let's see it says uh the participant
asks i was wondering if you have thought
about how to interact with indigenous
non-scientific non-western
interpretations of animal movements and
sounds indigenous groups throughout the
world have local alternative ways of
interpreting animal sounds and movements
for example the songs of certain birds
mean certain things for a particular
indigenous group and certain communities
have a history of imitating and
incorporating animal sounds into their
own musical practices and movement
practices so how have these modes of
listening and mapping sound how could
they be put in conversation with your
own projects very insightful questions i
love that question thank you so much for
bringing that up and someone who's from
the global south this is incredibly
important to me personally on every
single level including my science
um
and as an example the country i'm from
uruguay
actually means river of the painted
birds um gua means coming off e means
water and euro could mean um
zone off or a type of bird so um
everything in our language are reality
names of places have a variety of
different meaning depending on different
culture different score spiritual
practices so i'm incredibly excited of
um when i go to home this year in south
america and travel a little bit more
it's been hard with the covet 19
pandemic to learn more and listen
how
different animals have been perceived
through culture
especially as we start thinking about
for example in the united states lampard
movements and how this relates to the
cultural heritage of people this is a
great question
no it's a fantastic question so i i um
composed an opera a number of years ago
about uh
the the meeting of the europeans with
maori in new zealand so captain captain
cook first came and i collaborated with
a maori musician who was playing a
variety of instruments and she was a
trained musician but it wasn't a useful
conversation to sort of approach it from
a western perspective
so the most valuable thing to do is to
talk about the the story and the place
and the material
and the purpose of the of the
instruments that she was using and then
through that essentially kind of
dramaturgical um conversation we were
able to find a place for for that and
and the music so i think that the the
most important step of course is the
nature of the conversation and and
figuring out how to communicate so it's
a wonderful question and and you know i
would absolutely want to
um to investigate that and and the the
mighty name for new zealand at means
land of the long wait cloud so if we can
talk about origin origin names
anyway um
let me um take um
this moment to
once again
thank you both diego and matthew for an
absolutely wonderful journey what an
exciting inspiring project
and i think that you know the prospect
of conveying the urgency
of climate change the loss in
biodiversity
if sonification can
emotionally compel people to believing
it and
springing into action
gosh we would be living in a very
different world so
collectively we sort of i mean this was
absolutely thrilling we wish you very
well please keep us posted
with the work and um uh thank you so
much tai for um
helping set up the event and to guy for
a recording
um and making this all happen
and tai also thanks for handling these
wonderful questions
thanks to the audience for engaging so
deeply and asking such meaningful
questions
so before i draw the event to a close um
i just want to mention uh that
we have one other uh frankie fellow to
close out this season this year this
academic year dr anna florence a former
frankie fellow as well
uh who has
moved has gotten a faculty position at
columbia and she'll be talking to us
about
social and structural contours of
marginalization in the context of covet
19
are talking about her work with
marginalized groups
so uh once again thank you very much and
um bye everyone
and um matthew and diego this project is
just absolutely thrilling i hope you get
a chance to share it with many many more
people we'd be happy to advertise what
you're doing on our website
uh and matthew please do invite us to
your opera when it's done for sure yeah
and i think what is uh very exciting for
me as well was a recent nobel prize in
physics went to giorgio parisi who
actually worked out the collective
phenomena the description the language
to describe the motion of starlings for
example
which is the which is the same kind of
formalism that you would have to
describe the collective behavior of
atoms so it's the same underlying
framework that transcends
so your work is inspiring very similarly
with the kinds of applications thank you